and you just like didn't even tell us
that it was gonna happen oh yeah my bad
situations like this when you're merging
I should move oh I don't know hopefully
that me neither but have you been to a
hard day before yes have you ever been
into the stationery or the home decor
aisle did you ever watch Laguna Beach or
the hills I know on the show yes do you
know the girl Lauren Conrad you see the
blonde one I think they're all blonde
okay basically Lauren Conrad and Nate
Berkus I hope no one is offended by this
but they're very similar in the fact
that they make HomeGoods Beauty stuff
all flora does stationery like office
stuff I just want to be like that for
the younger demographic that YouTube
internet oh yeah
that's exactly I hope that becomes my
eyes awesome because your whole Genki
said it was I say Genki and the most
like positively possible well I only
take it ethic it's awesome I could I
could hella see you do that [ __ ] sick do
whenever you start making some crazy
janky [ __ ] look you know I love that
that's so dope should I be Martha
Stewart yeah I call it at the Stewart
the same age did you see Martha
Stewart's young pictures we don't I've
never had a DIY boner that is her this
is her that is Martha [ __ ] Street
she's doing so dirty because the
thoughts whoa TV she's like Daddy well
she no she did not
I just think that she is the ultimate
woman yes she's all in his love she's
wide open someone who was never spanked
as a kid growing up with like timeout
and stuff like that [ __ ] we can
imagine that thread they really have no
idea what that's like you've never
explained it to them you can't explain
that feeling of knowing of spanking or
there's no way to know where to go
you're just gonna figure yeah do you
have any idea how dope getting sent to
your room is that's tight yeah
especially as a teenager he's gone you
really jack off and you're [ __ ] good
to go like there's no there's no escape
from the beating so we talked about this
so I talked about some multiple JK
videos so I used to get beat by
something remember that then this green
bamboo stood they used to hold up plants
I used to get beat by that and I hated
that thing because here's the thing you
can hear it you can't see it but you can
hear it but it's so fast and then
yeah and for me it was a delayed
reaction because it was so fast
she was you're dead I hear it it just
burns out of nowhere it felt like
somebody branded me with a Scarlet
Letter yeah you're a idiot I hated that
[ __ ] your complexion raised yeah it just
has that bump yeah
out of nowhere see that's like who the
[ __ ] was the universal Asian pear that
said beat your kid with the green bamboo
stick you're fitna means watch Taiwanese
I'm Korean but we all got beat by the
same [ __ ] with a [ __ ] made that [ __ ]
it's like a whip yeah a palm tree it
just sways and with indestructible and I
remember when I got hit by it and it
finally broke on us I thank the heavens
I prayed about this and it would break
bread and it from behind the couch my
mom brought power there's a dusty 24
pack I remember is that 24 pack because
I remember it was yellow and blue and it
said 24 so in that first like 10 years
she was beating me with it she only used
that once those 23 more we don't even
have plans why do you have that louse
you guys ever have the experience where
so my mom I get my mom was the faintest
she was the one always doing is making
my dad just was so intimidating that we
always behavior but I remember the first
time I like dodged my mom like she got
so mad to pick up a stick returning to
me and I like done just jumped out of
the way and I remember thinking like
[Applause]
I've never done that before and then
let's see the look on her face and then
realizing okay
[Music]